what about personal responsibility I  think it's key I'll be honest like  there's a lot of expectations on  organizations to provide the solution to  every part of our lives at the moment  from kind of healthcare to mental health  and all this sort of stuff to be the  solution and  yes to an extent it's really important  those systems and those processes are in  place one thousand percent but there  also comes with a responsibility to want  to access them and and to create change  for for yourself as well and and that  kind of personal accountability and  personal responsibility in context to  mental health is is key the recruitment  mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by  VIN cherry and the award-winning Source  breaker